I've drawn it I've also put the center
on there because they talk about
radiuses radii so I'm going to need the
center measurement on there the tie
consists of four concentric circles the
inner circle has radius three
centimeters all right let me try that on
quickly
okay the radius of each larger circle
increases by two centers so when I go
from this one this one yet I guess that
one would have a radius of five so I'll
do it down here
that's the next circle up if you like
okay those are five the next one out
would have seven and that makes the
biggest circle nine okay so as you can
see my scale is not the greatest right
that that they're three is well that
nine is not three times longer but it's
close enough for us to make some
judgements on you a single darts thread
at random and it hits the target so we
assume their aim is good enough that
they don't like fly up here or something
like that
okay so there's somewhere on the dart
board find the probably that it hits
with in area P or I will start with that
okay now if you work here a probability
right you need to have favorable
outcomes I'm just going to write that
okay over the sample space right the
total number of things that can happen
okay
now the previous question we were
looking at we had a reader area shaded
area up here and a square down here
what's the total number of things that
could possibly happen hmm
how big is the dartboard
well let's let's try this because we're
looking at areas right you got to be
careful I take it that the sample space
all the things that could happen that's
the whole dartboard
is that okay you said that it's
somewhere on there yeah well where do
you square this 24 come from okay now I
need me to get on well now what are
these these are links aren't they okay
but the dark could hit like on an area
right so what I need to get for sample
space and for favored outcomes and they
both have to be areas of some kind okay
the question is what areas now I said
we're gonna keep the dot with somewhere
so I want the area of the whole dot
board area of the whole dot board okay
so it's a circle right so what's the
area of a circle we just talked about
this area of a circle that's an angle
it's PI r-squared right that's the area
second okay so what's the radius of the
whole dartboard
it's Mayan isn't it so no two pi times
nine square we can do nine square cut me
nine times nine it's 81 well done 81
pine okay centimeter square so that's
what I've got on my denominators that's
what that's what could possibly happen
okay now I want the probability that it
hits within area P that's inside here
that's a little circle right so this is
the dartboard area right dark woods area
what's the what's the area of this pot
in here area of P it's gonna pass wait
again right except it's a different
radius pi times what will the radius of
the small circle bit
they get to us right beginning right
it says the inner circle has radius 3
centimeters 3 squared is 9 right so I've
got 9 pi so there is my favorite cups
that's the part that I want to kill
right he's not gonna get a bull's-eye
but within the inside it's as good as it
gets
so there you go there's my probability
favorite ball over sample space I cancel
anything yes I can right what can I
cancel I can get to the PI's bad yeah
bigger can I cancel anything else hmm
anyone from that number come from
it was 9 squid wasn't it so I could
write 9 times like you couldn't I and I
can get rid of a night ok so there you
go I don't think I can cancel anything
else left because I've got one on the
top so it's 1 over 9 thank you that
makes sense see how we did it
we worked out what the areas where and
then we just cancel as far as we could
well because it was the last thing left
I don't have nothing over 9 I've got 1
over 9 so I'm not subtracting numbers
I'm dividing I divide you know when I
have this 2 over 6 okay
when I cancel here it's it's saying this
you divide this by 2 you divide this by
2 well 2 divided by 2 is not nothing
it's 1 right so that's why I write 1
there that make sense ok good question
last part of this it says find the
probably that a hits within area s sets
the outside boundary yes how do I work
out area yes hmm it's um if I shade it
looks like this
that they're the green shade area that's
area s how can I work it out hmm yeah
say that again
which rate which radius is which radius
are we talking about cuz it's quite a
few out there can I suggest do you
remember what we had before where we
started this lesson is quite similar
this right you had this guy and you are
interested in this area this shaded part
right so you're like you got a big shape
in this case it was a square and you cut
out a circle cut out a circle and you're
left with this shaded part right well
this green part yes yeah good I'm gonna
take the whole dark one which I've
already worked out 81:5 and then I've
got to take away this inside circle
which is radius seven okay
so here's what I'm gonna do it always
this putty or the pot one pot one no
that's right it's just there kind of as
a are just be the good sneaky yeah I
only need on so here's my probability to
get this green shaded area it's going to
be the whole dartboard
sorry probability because the whole
dartboard minus the area of that sucker
and be careful I think the area of I
actually mean that strip doesn't mean a
circle but anyway now like Kyle said
it's 49 okay yep
you actually work out oh yeah see what
you mean well so I've done the circle
that fits around us it's like the whole
thing I wrote all of those layers yeah
yeah okay so yeah it's fine as long as
you can distinguish between them that's
okay so that's that's this isn't an 81
pi minus coil Empire and it's still
divided by a 1 pi because it can still
hit anywhere on the dartboard yeah and
that's what that's what a 1 pie
represents the area of the whole bottle
can I cancel anything I can still cancel
pie gonna okay now be careful here
I've got 81 minus 49 on 81 said before I
do any canceling the numbers I should
probably work out 181 minus 4/9 is don't
know what it is I hope you do this in
the heads copy it's 32 you can sort of
see it's like 80 minus 50 almost so you
know it's around 30 and then you sort of
compensate with your nose was that a 32
on 81 it was close
can we cancel anything wait on that's it
okay so so that's why don't cancel
numbers too quickly has to be in common
between everything